hey you okay there  jesus i think i hurt someone  this is ed warren here with lorraine all  right let's get started  residents of brookfield were shocked  this afternoon by the broad daylight  murder of bruno sauls  the court accepts the existence of god  every time a witness swears to tell the  truth  i think it's about time they accept the  existence of the devil  whatever is going on whatever happened  that day that was not marnie  it's a witch's totem we think your  family was cursed  and that connection's still open  i'm only interested in reality  but i can see things that your people  can't  something terrible happened here  the master satanist is not an adversary  to be taken likely reaching out to the  darkness  lorraine you need to come back  you're saving him worth everything you  have  because that's what my fairy will cost  me  the right  [Music]